[Musique]
à l'occasion de la journée de la femme
le collège simon lucas se mobilisent et
organisent une action autour de la lutte
contre toutes les formes de violence
notamment celles qui touchent aux
enfants l'accent cette année et mise sur
la journée des droits de la femme mais
pas seulement
on a voulu au sein de cette journée
prendre un moment phare pour la décliner
sous divers actions de sensibilisation
et de prévention à partir de diverses
thématiques
nous sommes partis d'un travail
collaboratif sur le hashtag c'est non
non à toute forme de violence et de
discrimination non violence faite aux
femmes non violence faite à l'enfant et
aux discriminations et tout ce qui suit
harcèlement plusieurs activités
artistiques dont le thème ces noms
étaient proposés comme des expositions
de la photographie de la peinture mais
aussi un film sur l'égalité était
réalisée par un élève simplement mais
j'ai pris mon téléphone parce que je
devais leur lave émission c'est que j'ai
été nommé chef capsule par la principale
du collège pour demander aux gens dans
le collège ou à l'extérieur qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent qu est ce qu une femme
pourrait aujourd'hui interroger des gens
dans le collège à l'extérieur j'ai même
interrogée la mère d'un prof disick à 94
ans qui a vécu la deuxième guerre
mondiale
j'ai monté la vidéo je les donne à
arthur comme ça il peut il appela la
passe et ça c'est dur en plusieurs
étapes et la vidéo dure 28 minutes
plusieurs institutions et partenaires de
l'action étaient présents tels que la
vice-présidente du jus des enfants près
des tgi est aussi un docteur psychiatre
responsable de l'unité de psycho trauma
de l'aips s est maire de saint paul et
les parents d'élèves
alors nous avons des ateliers
lier l estime de soi liés comment dire
non qu'est-ce que le consentement
l'éducation affective l'éducation
amoureuse et sexuelle
donc en fait tout ce qui touche à la
prévention la prévention si des réseaux
sociaux
donc nous avons des partenaires comme la
gendarmerie de l'étang salé aujourd'hui
le docteur visnelda 12,1 également
docteur brugiroux donc que des docteurs
qui sont investis également dans la
prévention et dans la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
[Musique]